apparently taking a cue from Donald
Trump starting the homophobic attacks on
Ron DeSantis Donald Trump Jr now went on
another one of these manic rants this
time targeted at Ron DeSantis and he
basically says DeSantis is terrible in
every way that the DeSantis you think
might exist from TV reports doesn't
really exist this is getting very ugly
and it's only going to get worse
take a look
that's what it is guys he's owned by the
billionaire donors 100
controlled opposition let's see which
way the wind is blowing let's see which
way they want me to respond and I will
do it so I was hoping for a strong
response but we got a milk toast
response we got weaker than most Rhino
Republicans we got a weaker response
than a lot of never Trump Republicans
and guys here's the deal
you can hire influencers to post videos
of you dunking on what was like a hot
Twitter take 10 days ago on some more on
local reporter you can get plenty of
people to do that as Ron has
but that doesn't make you ready for the
big leagues if you can't understand that
this is a fundamental issue of our time
then you're not ready then it's not your
time as even people like Mike cernovich
who have been big DeSantis supporters
just heartbroken that DeSantis doesn't
understand what Soros DA's and the
Bolsheviks are going to do to this
country the Bolsheviks can you imagine
listen to this guy he also said to
Santa's blew it today the only people
saying otherwise personally hate Trump
or were never Trump in 16. and again
even some of those are coming out and
not just coming out like milk toast
they're coming out significantly
stronger than Governor DeSantis okay
again I know when you're ready for the
big leagues I spent a lot of time with
these guys I spent a lot of time with
the scientist personally the image
created online by the paid influencers
guys unfortunately one-on-one it doesn't
exist and this week made it clear so the
best and most accurate sign
that the Trump team sees DeSantis as a
real threat
is the amount of attention they have
paid to Ron DeSantis over the last two
weeks in particular
Trump posting daily on Troth Central
about Ron DeSantis Trump starting with
the homophobic smears against Ron
DeSantis Don Jr starting with the
attacks on Ron DeSantis uh people
associated with Trump including Steve
Bannon uh Mike pillow and others going
after Ron DeSantis you go after those
that you believe believe pose a threat
to you this is why Trump seemingly
encouraged Nikki Haley to run as far as
we know and is Going Bonkers attacking
Ron DeSantis he sees him as a threat
even though I still think it's important
to remember Trump is in a position of
power in the Republican primary if and
when the indictments come we will
evaluate how that changes those
prospects but if nothing changes this
really is Trump's nomination to lose